hey guys Pete here today I wanted to
talk about the log lady this is in my
series of character profiles of
characters and Twin Peaks the return and
like many people the log lady was always
one of my favorites in the original
series this will contain spoilers for
season three all the way up until now at
episode 10 but that's going to be at the
end of the video so I'll give another
spoiler warning at that point and we'll
talk about everything else first so you
don't have to click away yet if you
aren't caught up with season 3 through
part 10 and before I get into the
character I would like to talk about the
actress who played her Katherine Coulson
she passed away at age 71 back in 2015
and it's remarkable that when we see her
Twin Peaks started shooting on location
in the same month that she died so of
course they could have shot some of her
scenes since they were done on a
soundstage it has done them before hand
but when we see her in the return
it's basically at the very end of her
life she was suffering from cancer so
that adds an emotional layer for me
personally so I just want to talk a
little bit about her first she was an
associate of David Lynch's since the
1970s she worked as an assistant
director in the production of Eraserhead
one of his earliest and most notable
films she was actually going to act in
it as if she had a part but then they
changed things up and if you're familiar
is Eraserhead you know that the guy jack
man who played Pete Martell in the Twin
Peaks original series he has a starring
role in Eraserhead he was actually
married to the log Lady Catherine Colson
for a couple years before she married
her second husband and she had children
and all that after the fact so 20 peaks
is what I know her from she did several
other things in the industry
she acted all through her life and she
really developed an interesting
character the idea for the log Lady
actually was thought up way before Twin
Peaks actually came out it was also
conceived in the seven
eat when Lynch was going to do a TV show
that was going to be called I'll test my
logs with every branch of knowledge so
the concept basically was that this
person played by the same actress walked
around with the log she went around and
did a bunch of things with the log so
things it was changed a little bit for
Twin Peaks but the idea of her carrying
around the log came way before so in the
series she was known for walking around
with this log she was one of the
quirkiest of the quirky characters in
Twin Peaks she claimed that the log
could perceive different things
including events and basically new
things nobody else could hear the log
except for her and this pretty much made
everyone think she was crazy she also
spoke in a very puzzling sort of way but
the fact of the matter was is if you
looked at it the things that her log
said or that she interpreted from the
log were actually real things clearly
something supernatural was going on with
her in this log some of the members of
the book house boys like sheriff Harry
Truman and deputy Hawkes pretty much
recognized this and we saw this in the
original series that they didn't think
she was crazy later in the secret
history we get a detailed bio of her to
fill in the blanks like more information
about her and it's more of the same it
was written by dr. Jacobi's brother who
we never really saw in the television
series but he was a good friend of hers
and he basically defends her and also
explains her history leading up to what
we see in the television show so her
story starts out as a secret history
found out that when she was a child that
her and two other boys called rod who we
know from fire walk with me in season
three and a guy named Allen Trahan
went out on a camping trip and they
disappeared and we see that she did see
a doctor when they came back because of
intense thirst and hunger the kids
didn't realize they were gone very long
but they were actually gone for a couple
of days and when she returned she had a
pattern of red skin on the back
her right knee she graduated from Twin
Peaks high and then she went to
Evergreen University where she studied
wildlife management and forestry she
married a local logger Samson Sam
Lanterman and he wasn't just a logger he
was actually a super competitor in the
lumberjack competition like he won
everything and eventually stopped
competing so that other people had a
chance to win King I'm not gonna go into
their whole story but yeah they were
together for a year they married a year
to the day after they first met very
old-fashioned courting and he supposedly
fell for her right away when he saw her
doing some work and they just for
someone who had never really been like
the dating type or the marrying type
date these two just hit it off right
away
unfortunately on their wedding night
there was a big fire Sam was killed
because he was also a local volunteer
fireman and when he went to go find it's
like the blaze he fell into a ravine the
next day she went up into the mountains
around the in the area around
Glastonbury Grove and she cut a log from
a Douglas fir that had fallen during
that same fire and that's where she got
her log and she carried around with her
from then on in 1983 we know that Laura
Palmer visited Margaret and the log lady
told her about owls and several things
that she knew about Laura on the night
of February 18th 1989 we saw Margaret
stop Laura outside the local Roadhouse
and fire walk with me she basically
placed her hand on the logs and put it
on Laura's forehead and she said when
this kind of fire starts it's very hard
to put out the tender bowels of
innocence burn first and the wind rises
and then all goodness is in jeopardy on
the night of February 23rd when Laura
was murdered the log lady cried in
cradled her log at home
next time we saw her was when Special
Agent Cooper has called people together
to talk about them taking over the
murder investigation we saw Margaret
click the lights on and off chuffing
everybody in the audience after that she
shows up at the Double R and she hears
Cooper talking about Laura so she goes
over and she says that her log saw
something the night of the murder and
she told Cooper to ask it but he doesn't
say anything so she just walks away
she was at Laura's funeral a couple days
later and then after that we had that
scene where we had deputy ha Cooper dr.
Hayward and harry s truman all went to
her cabin where she was actually waiting
for them she tells them that they were
two days late she gave them a little
explanation about her husband who was a
logger and said how he met the devil in
the form of fire the day after their
wedding and this is when Hawk has that
quote where he says that the wood holds
many spirits again she says that her log
saw something the night of Laura's
murder and she shows it to Cooper and
then she speaks for the log and says
that it's a darkness laughter owls
flying two men two girls flashlights in
the woods over the ridge quiet and then
footsteps of a man and then not long
after she alleged the log heard the
screams of a girl further up over the
ridge we saw that she has a strange
habit of chewing that gum which she
would spit out and you know we saw her
stick it against the wall in the double
r we saw her meet up with major Briggs
at the double r and they talked about
his markings on the back of his neck
from whenever he went away and she tells
him the log has a message and she and
the message is deliver the message and
that's I talked about this among major
Briggs breakdown he understands what
this means and he goes off to the
sheriff and agent Cooper she also visits
them at the Sheriff's Department and
tells them they're owls in the road
else and she told Cooper that something
was happening they all went together and
she basically ate a bunch of peanut we
saw her dougie Milford's wedding she
didn't do much so she just said
basically that she has loved Milford
weddings because they were you know
married quite a few times her and Briggs
went together to the sheriff's
department to show them their markings
remember Briggs are three triangles and
hers are the two peaks like the two
mountains she says that she remembered
hearing the call of an owl when she
received these markings as a child and
she also heard that sound before her
husband died we saw her at the myth Twin
Peaks contest we also know that when the
Merle impersonated her there he was
trying to abduct the Queen which turned
out to be Annie and he did that Pete
Martel's because of that thought that
she had stolen his truck but it was
actually Windom Earle and she brought
along a jar with oil in it too agent
Cooper which her husband retrieved and
said was he called extra say and opening
to a gateway so that's everything that
we learned from the secret history and
what we saw in the original series now
25 years later so yeah if you're not
caught up in season three you might want
to stop watching now 25 years later we
saw her she is sick at home she has to
use an oxygen mask she calls up talked
at the Sheriff's Office
and she tells them that something's
missing and that he has to find it it's
related to aging Cooper and the way that
he was going to find it had something to
do with his heritage
she later called him on his phone when
we saw him approaching Glastonbury Grove
which I talked about in my Hawk video
because it really doesn't make a lot of
sense but she says here that the stars
turned in the time presents itself and
then asked him to come by and tell her
what happened at her cabin and you know
she'll have pie and coffee for him then
in part 10 we heard her call Hawk once
again and this is where she goes into
the lore is the
once Pete you know it boiled down to her
saying that the presence of electricity
was around and it was fading it was a
fading glow the Truman's were good
people they were true men and they were
Hawks brothers
she said the circle was almost complete
and she told hawk to watch and listen to
the dream of time and space
it all comes out now flowing like a
river that which is and is not and at
the end she said Laura is the one now I
brought this up in that ten things you
might have missed video that she said
something very similar to this in the
log lady intros those intros were
written by Lynch for her and they
coincided with the show being shown in
syndication on the Bravo's Network some
interesting things about her is that the
scar that she has we saw in the show it
was the two peaks but in the secret
history is described as like the marking
that major Briggs has but when it was
rearranged by agent Cooper so that is
the strange anomaly one of the many ones
from the secret history to the show one
of the big fan theories about her has
always been that one of the woodsmen
that we saw in the meeting room above
the convenience store the guys that were
known as the woodsman one of them was
her husband of course an obvious theory
is that her husband's inside the log
because she got it today after he died
and we had that comment from Hawke about
the wood holding many spirits and then
we also saw when Josie died that she was
trapped in a wooden door or wooden not
nod to a drawer in the Great Northern
but whenever she was asked about it the
actress Katherine Coulson was asked
about she said that the log to her was
more like a memento of the log ladies
late husband that's the way that she
always saw it another interesting thing
was that in Deer meadow that sort of
strange little woman that comes in
whenever a Dean Stanton is talking to
Esmond that lady is wearing the same
sweater as the log lady same print
anyways
oh no but the exact same sweater so yeah
she's always been a cool character she's
always stood out as mysterious but also
you kind of had a feeling that there was
a reason for her being there like she
probably knew something obviously when
we saw the call rod could see thing in
season three that kind of added a little
bit more validity to what her log
actually does like that it is a
spiritual connection that she has I mean
I used the word spiritual because I
don't know what else to say but she does
see things in advance and then she
delivers them as riddle so it's not
always useful but it always turns out to
be true in the end so I'm hoping that
we'll see more of her and get more of
her if you're a fan of the character you
should definitely I mean you should read
the secret history of Twin Peaks anyways
like it it's really worth it I have a
link in my video description where you
can find this but if you're a fan of a
log Lady the the story there about her
childhood it's very interesting and it's
kind of a little bit quirky but it gives
you a whole different perspective on her
I mean I went through the major parts
but you know there's a lot more there
and it's definitely worth checking out
so what do you think primarily what do
you think about what she said in the
last episode the estate Hawk actually
understands what she says a lot of
people think that when she was talking
to him on the cell phone when he went up
to Glastonbury Grove but that was out of
sequence so that has yet to happen I
really don't know how I feel about that
yet but it is a thing I made a whole
video about I mean what the hell
happened there you know he we saw him
show up we saw her call but no one's
mentioned it then and do you think she's
going to play a big part in the rest of
the series this video is getting long I
could talk about her and basically
ramble on but I'm going to cut it short
here please like the video if you
enjoyed it let me know who you want to
see another character profile on I would
like to do it there's so many of those
intros someone brought it up doing an
intro
those interns I may do that could let me
know if you'd like to see that it's just
too long to put together with the
character profile please subscribe to my
channel check back regularly because I
got a ton of twin peak stuff coming out
until the return winds up please follow
me on Twitter and my other social media
accounts and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon